das vw-werk in wolfsburg hier traf der
korona crash die deutsche wirtschaft
unmittelbar und besonders heftig mitte
märz der größte deutsche konzern
plötzlich lahmgelegt im herzen der
wichtigsten deutschen branche stehen die
bänder still
corona der super gau denn
funktionierende lieferketten sind für vw
unverzichtbar
die teile für die produktion in
wolfsburg kommen aus der ganzen welt
allein in china hat volkswagen 26
standorte in wolfsburg stauen sich
unverkaufter autos
mitarbeiter fürchten um ihre
arbeitsplätze vw chef herbert diess
sieht sich gezwungen fabriken
vorübergehend zu schließen
angesichts der sich aktuell deutlich
verschlechternden absatzlage und der
sich abzeichnenden unsicherheit bei der
teileversorgung unserer werke wird es an
den standorten unserer marken
unmittelbar auch zu
produktionsunterbrechungen kommen
die globalisierung hat die
erfolgsgeschichte von volkswagen erst
möglich gemacht
auch die konkurrenten daimler und bmw
haben ihre produktionsstandorte in der
ganzen welt verteilt und erfahren in der
pandemie welche risiken die
internationale verflechtung mit sich
bringt der deutsch französische
pharmariese sanofi hat genau das erkannt
outsourcing die auslagerung von
produktion ist zwar oft billiger doch je
weniger zulieferer man hat desto
anfälliger ist die versorgung besonders
bei medikamenten kann die
diversifizierung daher lebensrettend
sein
in frankfurt-höchst stellt sanofi die
grund wirkstoffe für viele medikamente
her in risiken apparaten werden dafür
tonnenweise chemikalien gemixt sowie bei
fag sowie nadine einem mittel gegen
allergien
der wirkstoff wird später mit
hilfsstoffen vermischt und zu einem
fertigen arzneimittel dosiert erklärt
sanofi manager matthias braun
welche bedeutung haben die globalen
lieferketten für die herstellung solcher
wirkstoffe sowie hat typischerweise noch
eine relativ hohe fertigungstiefe heißt
wir machen auch aus qualitätsgründen
eine ganze menge selbst und sanofi hat
die politik das für jedes produkt was
zugekauft wird mindestens zwei
lieferanten existieren die auch in
unterschiedlichen geografin angesiedelt
sein soll
damit wir über die ganzen ketten
sicherstellen können dass wir nicht von
einem
lieferanten abhängig sind weil sich die
produktion in europa kaum noch rechnete
haben viele pharma produzenten ihre
fabriken in den letzten jahrzehnten nach
asien verlagert dort sind arbeitskräfte
billig umwelt und sicherheitsstandards
niedrig so kommt es dass 60 prozent der
global benötigten arzneimittelwirkstoffe
nur noch in asien hergestellt werden in
westeuropa gerade noch rund 28 prozent
in nordamerika 5 prozent sowie sieben
prozent in anderen ländern aufgrund
dieser abhängigkeit besonders von indien
und china konnte es deshalb in der
pandemie zu dramatischen engpässen
kommen
um dies in zukunft zu vermeiden plant
sanofi die gründung eines europäischen
wirkstoff champions dafür will der
konzern sechs seiner wirkstoff fabriken
abspalten und externe investoren für die
neu gegründete firma gewinnen der
börsengang ist im frühjahr 2022 geplant
unter der leitung des erfahrenen
managers
wir dürfen nicht naiv sein wir werden
nicht 100 prozent aller wirkstoffe nach
europa zurück holen aber wir müssen
schnellstmöglich diese totale
abhängigkeit von asien bei vier zu
vielen wirkstoffen beenden
mehrere hersteller in verschiedenen
ländern das klingt nach einer guten idee
wenn jedoch alle länder betroffen sind
wie bei einer pandemie hilft auch das
wenig welche konsequenzen müssen also
firmen aus dem störfall corona ziehen
wenn es anderswo billiger ist verlagert
man die produktion das war die bisherige
logik glauben sie die pandemie ändert
diese rechnung
ein grund warum die produktion verlagert
oder warum es diese fragmentierten
lieferketten gibt sind die niedriglöhne
im rest der welt
aber sobald eintönige prozesse von
maschinen erledigt automatisiert von
robotern übernommen werden sind billiger
arbeitskräfte kein wettbewerbsvorteil
den welthandel und die internationale
arbeitsteilung zurückschrauben geht das
münchner ifo institut untersucht die
handelsexpertin lee sandra flach mit
ihrem team die folgen und risiken der
globalisierung
sie war davor dass deutschland sich im
zuge der korona krise zu sehr nach außen
abschottet
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
deutschland sehr stark von der
globalisierung profitiert und wenn wir
jetzt denken dass wir die produktion
nach deutschland zurückholen sollen dann
muss uns auch klar sein dass wir
aufgeben
und zwar nicht wenig wir werden ärmer
und zwar zeigen wir dass er in eine der
globalisierten welt würden wir einen
rückgang im realeinkommen von fast 20
prozent erleben das ist mehr
versorgungssicherheit oder geringere
kosten
dass es die entscheidung welche folgen
hätte denn einen rückzug von der
globalisierung für deutschland
regionalisierung der lieferkette ist
keine lösung für die aktuelle krise
sondern eher eine diversifizierung der
lieferkette in bezug auf zulieferer
also das heißt die unternehmen werden
bewusst die produkte von mehrere
zulieferer aus verschiedenen regionen
beschaffen um die risiken davon
lieferausfälle zu minimieren was
globalisierung bedeutet sieht man in
einer branche besser als kaum irgendwo
sonst in der textilindustrie wie unter
einem brennglas zeigen sich hier die
vorteile aber auch die schattenseiten
der globalen produktion
bangladesch nordöstlicher nachbar
indiens 165 millionen menschen leben
hier mehr als doppelt so viele einwohner
wie in deutschland
das land hat dank der globalisierung
eine beachtliche erfolgsgeschichte
geschrieben
seit den 90er jahren hat die wirtschaft
hier kontinuierlich zwischen vier und
acht prozent zugelegt wachstumsmotor
nummer eins die textilindustrie
größter abnehmer der willig mode ist mit
großem abstand deutschland wie in dieser
fabrik in dakar schuftet ein heer von
näherinnen unermüdlich für westliche
labels wie levi's madsen spencer oder
bershka millionen jobs sind so
entstanden
doch nun rächt sich die einseitige
exportstrategie wie in deutschland
mussten in der pandemie geschäfte
schließen und globale modekonzerne haben
milliardenschwere aufträge in
bangladesch storniert hunderte fabriken
wurden dichtgemacht zehntausende
menschen hauptsächlich frauen und ihre
familien sind akut von armut bedroht
eine von ihnen ist janine akte x ek sie
ist 35 jahre alt und lebt in gossip uhr
einer textil stadtnahe dakar
als näherin hat sie monatlich rund 125
dollar verdient doch seit ihre fabrik
geschlossen wurde hat sie keinen
richtigen job mehr und kaum noch geld um
essen für ihre drei kleinen söhne zu
kaufen
die globalisierung brachte ihr zwar
keinen wohlstand aber stabile
lebensverhältnisse wegen des corona
virus leiden wir nun hunger wir sind
verarmt früher aber unser einkommen viel
höher und wir konnten uns dinge viel
einfacher leisten jetzt ist das geld
weniger wert und die preise für alle
sind gestiegen für leute die viel
verdienen ist das kein problem aber
menschen wie uns die zu den armen
gehören hat es in extreme not gestürzt
das ist jetzt die realität das ist keine
erfindung ist absolut
sie musste sich geld leihen meinen job
als putzhilfe suchen zurückzahlen können
sie die schulden nicht alles was sie
verdient geht für essen und schulgeld
drauf ich habe keine chance zu überleben
ich habe meinen vater verloren einen
bruder
ich bin allein und meine kinder sind
noch klein mein mann hat eine andere
frau geheiratet und mich mit den kindern
zurück gelassen aber ich kann nicht
einfach wieder heiraten das würde meinen
namen entehren ich muss an die kinder
denken in bangladesch bekommen
arbeitslose keine unterstützung
kurzarbeit oder sozialhilfe gibt es
nicht auf zahlen fabrikbesitzer nicht
einmal die vorgeschriebenen abfindungen
milliardenschwere konjunkturpakete kann
sich der staat nicht leisten
näherinnen wie marika bleibt nur wütend
an den werkstoren zu rütteln und um
einen job zu betteln
jeden morgen sammeln sich dort lange
schlangen von arbeitslosen
aktivisten karl pohler acta kennt die
probleme mit zwölf fing sie selbst als
nähren in einer fabrik an mehr als 30
jahre später hilft sie den arbeiterinnen
ihre rechte durchzusetzen
die verantwortung für das elend sieht
sie nicht nur bei der regierung in
bangladesch die westliche mode labels
haben sich in dieser krise so
rücksichtslos verhalten
sie sind einfach abgehauen und haben
ihre aufträge storniert oder verschoben
ihre geschäftspartner hier waren ihnen
egal
genauso wie die arbeiter die seit jahren
für sie die profite machen
sie haben sie an der ausgestreckten hand
verhungern lassen
die internationale arbeitsorganisation
der vereinten nationen in genf die uno
warnt bereits dass die pandemie in den
entwicklungsländern das leben von
millionen menschen bedroht denn ohne
arbeit haben sie kein einkommen
die elo schätzt dass bereits fast 500
millionen jobs durch die korona krise
vernichtet worden
san jose ist direktor des beschäftigungs
programms der eu für ihn verstärkt die
pandemie eine massive
gerechtigkeitslücke zwischen dem westen
und dem rest der welt besonders den
schwellen und entwicklungsländern
[Musik]
das ist eine schwere zeit für alle aber
es ist die zeit der globalen solidarität
wir müssen wirklich besorgt hat denn das
risiko von armut und hunger und
ernsthaften gesundheitsschäden ist groß
das ist eine frage des überlebens
[Musik]
grundsätzlich gilt soziale verantwortung
der konzerne für ihre zulieferfirmen ist
bisher freiwillig das könnte sich jetzt
ändern
die korona krise zeigt dass wir
letztlich alle in einem boot sitzen
ein erster schritt könnte das
lieferketten gesetz sein
es würde firmen verpflichten die
einhaltung menschenwürdige arbeits und
sozialstandards bei ihren zulieferfirmen
zu prüfen und durchzusetzen
faire produktionsbedingungen wären dann
auch außerhalb deutschlands pflicht kein
almosen
viele konzerne sagen zumindest dass sie
mehr globale verantwortung übernehmen
wollen
auch einige große player haben sich dazu
bekannt das gesetz unterstützen zu
wollen etwa rewe cry macho und nestlé
die spitzenverbände der deutschen
wirtschaft halten es dagegen für
überzogen gerne hätten wir mit bda bdi
und dihk darüber gesprochen aber keiner
der verbände will uns ein interview
geben schriftlich heißt es vom bdi die
forderung für eine zivilrechtliche
haftung ist realitätsfern komplexe
lieferketten seien aus deutschland
heraus überhaupt nicht zu kontrollieren
und vom bdr
das gesetz sei ungerecht und verlagere
staatsversagen dem private haftung
deshalb werden wir uns auch weiter dafür
einsetzen dass das gesetz in dieser
geplanten form nicht kommen wird das
lieferketten gesetz wäre ein schritt in
die richtige richtung glauben viele aber
wird es grundsätzlich an der weltweiten
spaltung in arm und reich etwas ändern
muhammad yunus gründete eine bank in
bangladesch die armen mikrokredite gibt
dafür wurde er mit dem
friedensnobelpreis ausgezeichnet
unermüdlich kämpft er gegen die
weltweite ungerechtigkeit im zuge der
globalisierung
[Musik]
fast 60 prozent aller menschen auf der
welt leben von der hand in den nächsten
tag für die woche für woche
obwohl eigentlich genug für alle da ist
aber der gesamte reichtum der welt liegt
in ganz wenigen hennings diese extreme
vermögenskonzentration die unser system
erzeugt ist der grund für das leid
also ist die pandemie ihren wendepunkt
die pandemie hat eine situation
geschaffen in der wir reflektieren kann
weil unsere normalen aktivitäten
gestoppt
jetzt haben wir viel zeit nachzudenken
die pandemie hat den zug angehalten
das verschafft uns eine gelegenheit wir
können einen neuen zug und neue gleise
bauen und in eine andere richtung
weiterfahren nicht wo wir im moment
hinfahren den zug in eine andere
richtung lenken wie soll das
funktionieren kann eine pandemie
menschen zum umdenken bringen
der störfall krone hat allen vor augen
geführt wie unsere lebensweise der
umwelt anderen menschen und uns selbst
schadet die umwelt atmete kurz auf
während des ersten shutdowns im frühjahr
ging die luftverschmutzung drastisch
zurück wie satelliten aufnahmen der
europäischen raumfahrtagentur esa zeigen
über china etwa sammelte sich nur halb
so viel stickoxid wie sonst über los
angeles verschwand der smog in indien
sah man die gipfel des himalaya am
horizont
und in vielen städten europas gingen die
stickoxid emissionen um bis zu 50
prozent zurück etwa in mailand madrid
und paris immer billiger immer schneller
immer mehr unser westlicher lebensstil
fordert einen hohen preis jetzt wo alle
ausgebremst werden dämmert es fehlen
dass man etwas ändern könnte auch in
deutschen firmen beginnt das umdenken
sowie bei der allianz versicherung in
der korona zwangspause schickte sie fast
90 prozent ihrer mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter nach hause
noch immer ist in den büros deutlich
mehr platz als vor der krise so wie bei
vielen konzernen wegen der pandemie
arbeiten viele beschäftigte im
home-office der büroalltag hat sich in
ganz deutschland komplett verändert sind
ja wirklich merklich weniger leute hier
im büro wie viel prozent der mitarbeiter
kommt dann überhaupt noch ich würde mal
sagen so im schnitt um die 25 prozent
sind im büro und den rest zuhause und ob
sie funktioniert habe und trotzdem
funktioniert wunderbar es gibt kollegen
die 100% ins büro kommen und es gibt
kollegen die 100% zu hause arbeiten und
alles dazwischen
ich glaube der große wunsch ist auch
dass man sich das aussuchen darf also
dass keiner hier möchte wieder zurück in
die alte bürowelt ein praktischer
nebeneffekt für die allianz ist
natürlich auch noch dass es geld sport
oder das stimmt und das ist ja nicht
schlimm ich meine ist sehr gut
man spart strom und natürlich gehört
dazu auch die reduktion von dienstreisen
also wir wollen 50 prozent weniger
reisen und mehr digitale technologien
nutzen um uns zu treffen also auf jeden
fall ist es auch eine ersparnis für das
unternehmen ja so ist es bei den meisten
dax-konzerne
viele wollen nach der krise nicht zurück
in die zeit vor corona
jedenfalls nicht wenn sie dabei geld
sparen können auch das ökologische
einsparpotenzial ist groß wenn nur ein
viertel der erwerbstätigen in
deutschland einen tag mehr von zu hause
arbeiten würde könnte der co2 ausstoß
des pendelverkehrs dadurch um fünf
prozent sinken
bei zwei zusätzlichen tagen home office
pro woche würden 11 prozent der
emissionen wegfallen
anders arbeiten anders konsumieren auch
in der bekleidungsindustrie hat corona
über den ersten shut down hinaus spuren
hinterlassen
es wird mehr online bestellt leben
klagen über kundenschwund und manch
einer merkt dass sie viel weniger
kleidung braucht dass man sachen länger
tragen kann als eine saison
slow fashion ein trend der in diese
richtung weist
bei der kleider tauschbörse closings
überhaupt kann man gebrauchte kleidung
tauschen die kanadierin jennas dahin ist
gründerin der tauschbörse und freut sich
jedes mal wenn gebrauchtes einen neuen
liebhaber findet mindestens fünf teile
muss man mitbringen und darf so viel
mitnehmen wie man möchte
schauen wir was ich gefunden haben 222
helfen und 123 hosen wie viel würde das
im laden kosten was denkst du da würde
ich auch schätzen das ist doch absurd
warum schmeißen die leute das weg ich
glaube wir shoppen trends und marotten
hinterher und der vorstellung dass wir
ständig etwas neues brauchen
ich glaube insgesamt dass wir über
konsumieren
es liegt in der menschlichen natur dass
wir immer mehr besitzen
aber ich sehe dass wir eigentlich hier
weniger brauchen
es gibt hoffnung auf veränderte
spielregeln
denn die pandemie zeigt die weltweite
ungleichheit wie unter einem brennglas
aber für die nötigen korrekturen braucht
es mut
wir wissen was zu tun ist aber wir
handeln nicht wissen wer für die
konzentration des reichtums
verantwortlich ist warum das so ist wir
wissen es wir wollen es einfach nur
nicht ändern
es geht nur um profitmaximierung das
einzige worauf wir unsere wirtschafts
maschine programmiert haben ist profit
maxi wie werden wir also auf diese krise
zurückblicken und nehmen wir sie zum
anlass um die globalisierung zum
positiven zu verändern
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass wir sie als bruch
begreifen als weckruf war verheerend das
versagen unseres jetzigen systems ist
ich hoffe dass wir die globalisierung
regulieren können sodass sie gerechter
und nachhaltiger damit wir von ihren
guten seiten profitieren und ihre
schattenseiten bekämpfen können dafür
müssen sich nicht 205 länder einig sein
es reicht wenn die großen player die
etwas verändern können auch wirklich
etwas verändern
die verantwortlichen in der welt sind
gefragt sich auf neue spielregeln zu
einigen damit globalisierung nicht
länger grenzenlosen profit für wenige
sondern mehr wohlstand für alle bedeutet
nach der pandemie ist das noch wichtiger
als zuvor
[Musik]